In this lesson, we're going to discuss a healthcare
application of clustering called phenotyping.
Phenotypes are medical concepts such as diseases
or conditions.
We know many phenotypes of patients based
on existing medical knowledge such as major
diseases.
But there are many more phenotypes and their
subtypes out there that we haven't discovered.
Computational phenotyping is a way to use
data available to us to discover those novel
phenotypes.
Phenotypes aren't just for disease diagnosis,
though.
We can also use those phenotypes for predicting
healthcare cost, readmission risk, and supporting
genomic studies.
Now let's talk about computational phenotyping.
Computational phenotyping is about converting
raw electronic health record through phenotyping
algorithms into a set of meaningful medical
concepts, or phenotypes.
For example, a specific disease can be a phenotype.
Such as type 2 diabetes.
And the raw data, in this case, consists of
many different sources.
Such as demographics about patients, diagnosis
code, medication information, clinical procedure,
lab result, and clinical notes.
There are many reasons why phenotypes are
not represented consistently or reliably in
the raw data.
First, the data are noisy, there are missing
data and raw information in the raw data.
And second, the main usage of this data is
to support clinical operations, such as billing.
And it's not designed directly for supporting
research.
Third, there are many overlapping and redundant
information.
For example, diagnosis information can be
found in the structure field corresponding
to diagnosis code.
But the same information can also be present
as end structure information in the clinical
notes.
This information is overlapping and redundant
in the raw data.
And phenotyping is this process of deriving
research grade phenotypes from clinical data,
using computer algorithms.
Here's a phenotyping algorithm for Type 2
diabetes.
And the goal here is, we want to determine
whether patient has Type 2 diabetes based
on her electronic health records.
For example, we can first check whether the
patient has Type 1 diabetes code in her record.
If no, then we check whether Type 2 diabetes
diagnosis are present in her record.
If still no, then we check medication for
Type 2 diabetes.
Then, check abnormal lab result related to
diabetes.
If these two steps are confirmed then we confirm
she has Type 2 diabetes.
There are many different paths that can lead
to the confirmation of Type 2 diabetes, and
this decision flow is a phenotyping algorithm.
This was developed manually by clinical experts.
There are many different applications that
require phenotyping.
For example, genomic study, which is about
finding relationship between genomic data
and phenotypic data.
Clinical predictive modeling, which is about
building an accurate, robust, and interpretable
prediction model about disease onset and other
related targets, such as hospitalization.
And pragmatic clinical trials, which is about
comparing treatment effectiveness in the real
world clinical environment using observational
data, like electronic health records.
And healthcare quality measurement, which
is about measuring efficiency and quality
of care across different hospitals.
All those applications depends on phenotyping
algorithms.